We're told to factor r squared
plus 4r, minus 45.
And there are simpler ways to
factor this, because this has
1 as a leading coefficient on
the r squared right here, but
what we're going to do
is we're going to
factor this by grouping.
And when you factor it by
grouping, what you want to do
is find two numbers whose
product-- so the two numbers
are a and b-- whose product is
equal to the coefficient on r
squared, 1 times negative 45,
which is just negative 45.
And whose sum is equal to the
coefficient on the first
degree term, is equal to 4.
a plus b is equal to 4.
So let's look at all of the
different combinations that
goes to negative 45, and see
if when you add them,
you ever get to 4.
So let's take the
combinations.
Let's look at their different
a's and b's, and let's see
what happens when
you sum them.
So I could try 1 and negative
45, but if you take their sum,
that's not going to get you
anywhere close to 4, even if
you swapped them, negative
1 and positive 45.
Let's see, if you do 3 and 15, 3
and negative 15, or negative
3 and 15, those are way
more than 4 apart.
We're going to have
to find numbers
that are closer together.
So let's see, 3, 4, 5 and 9,
that looks interesting.
5 and 9 are 4 apart.
And if we go with 5 and negative
9, what's their sum?
Their sum is negative 4.
What happens if we go with
negative 5 and positive 9?
Well, then their sum
is 4, so negative 5
and positive 9 works.
So what we want to do here, now
that we found the numbers
whose product is equal to the 1
times negative 45, and whose
sum is equal to 4, let's break
this 4r up into a sum of
negative 5-- let me break
it up this way--
into 9r minus 5r.
I broke that 4r into that using
our two numbers, and
then I could put the r squared
out front, r squared, and then
we have a minus 45.
And now we're ready
to group this and
then factor by grouping.
So let's look at this first
group right here.
They both have the common
factor of r, so let's
factor out an r.
This is equal to r times-- r
square divided by r is r.
9r divided by r is 9.
So that's that first group.
And the second group right here,
has a common factor of
negative 5.
So let's factor it out.
Negative 5r divided by negative
5 is just an r.
Negative 45 divided by
negative 5 is a 9.
And then we have an r plus 9 in
both terms. r times r plus
9, negative 5 times r plus 9.
So we can factor that out.
So you factor an r plus 9 out,
and you're left with r times r
plus 9, divided by r plus 9
is just going to be an r.
And then negative 5 times r plus
9, divided by r plus 9 is
negative 5, and we're done!